were so full podcast welcome to the
Warsaw food podcast where every Friday
we'll bring you the were so full podcast
with your host Felipe Esparza and
Rodrigo Torres co-host yeah man
yes and we have all guests you will get
back to here man yes we want to spoil it
for you guys bad but anyway so he's over
there managing the wielders deal keeping
us up-to-date with stuff that we already
know anyway so it is just the two of us
though the secret is out
it salary no we have no guest I'm gonna
lean on them for a while and then have
him thinking about it wait a minute
where's the guest I don't forget [ __ ]
dad I got gypped it's just the two of us
vision is the what's awful part cat cow
just the two of us with Adam Murray
that's it get to the point what's up
fool what's up man all right so first to
cover man first of all I want to thank
everybody everybody that kept it 100 and
you know what I mean when I do kept it
100 we've read the reviews you put on
iTunes but that wasn't enough that
reached us only to 191 damn and that was
because of you guys pushing and writing
down those reviews I think we kinda like
20 of them there's a lot of them but we
need more more more 50,000 listens okay
hell yeah so all we need is 1% of you
guys of the 50,000 listen the lesson our
week to put in a review that means that
only
500 of you guys gotta leave a message
that 1% [ __ ] that
let's just lower that [ __ ] so nice ratio
half of 1% damn 50 of you guys not even
that man I would all just say let's go
for one person a day leave a review how
about that I'm gonna leave you review
[ __ ] it doc I don't know how to let you
put you can't we can all cuz you have
the count
[ __ ] that i'ma put one anyway yeah man
though some people asking if you're
gonna come to Dallas and some guy said
he probably won't be there cuz I already
got too big now he got too small you got
your big bro doing a Yemenite podcast in
the garage too big tio
too big here right you're too bigger too
big to be continued and set it to
Variety magazine hell yeah bro come on
Brad you gotta get a TMZ we passed by
TMZ one time they got total what's up
turn the camera off and put it down hey
man oh my god what's up fool upcoming
shows September 15 and 16 San Jose
California the first show Friday show
7:30 show it's sold out already so
there's plenty of tickets for the third
show on Saturday so man you know man if
you are in the triple G and hello fight
ends early hey you know what puts the
communist go watch comedy at the
Hollywood improv I'll be there sorry my
bad I'm gonna scratch that [ __ ] out too
and the Hollywood you get hurt and so
we're gonna just be there at the heart
at the San Jose improv three shows
Friday Saturday Rodrigo Torres Adam
Murray in the house what's up he'll be
other hand you know dumb jellyfishes too
Johnny rocky and much of us are driving
yeah yeah be hanging out but who's
talking about we should go do a video
and Sunday we should but we're not
because I'm leaving on Sunday
[ __ ] seven early man early
anyway so September the 21st to 24th
Houston Texas houston we have a problem
Houston improv I will be donating half
of the proceeds to a couple of charities
in Houston the Houston Food Bank and
friends for life animal shelter friends
for life I don't shout sir is a no kill
zone shelter that means some some
shelter you know dog is too old a rabid
gets too old put they're full of sleep
make room for the next animal nah man at
this place the animals get live out
their days or age bro - then they in
like you're an old man and he's a pet
your old man who's 75 years old
[ __ ] it no [ __ ] you can adopt a dog just
out of your ass bro together okay little
buddy
yeah man man there was I don't know if
you saw the floods but there are some
dogs or just I'll use the word that Ted
Cruz and the Democrats and the
Republicans like using during disasters
they showed a lot of resilience a lot of
animal with resilience I thought well
man I saw this shelter
that's funny when nowadays people call
it shelters when I was a kid it was
called a [ __ ] dog pound hell yeah man
the stray cat get in the truck TV show
pound puppies give me a paw at the teddy
bear dog yeah yeah you said they're at
the pound they call it a dog pound yeah
you were leased to a podcast
white people no Lisa hey Matt yeah it's
called the pound cast buddy pick it up
pound puppies I saw this video not a
video it was a meme of this chubby lady
and I Love New Orleans and and she has a
booth exposed exposed but their ever
liked her they have body painted on the
right and they're both hound dogs ii
suck on these puppies yeah let the dogs
run a search
there's snippy bro yeah man that's about
the homeless chick we saw yesterday
like it was covering her bellybutton
they're hanging I've never seen boobs
that big they're huge
where you been the clean part of Orlando
yeah man so they were hounds bro I bet
somebody wrote ya man somebody need to
call them dogs back who the funniest
[ __ ] I've seen last night there was this
there was it like trailer trash dude
from somewhere you know for the trailer
parks of Florida you know you know and
you get invited to a black family
reunion from a neighbor come in
therefore cuz you know sometimes bro
you're going with your family you're
leaving
you bring all your family leaving
somewhere but there's a different
neighborhood just there that you leave
me like like he wanna go yeah like Ivan
bro for all the status need to watch
where was irate would drop us up at the
airport and I'm off up a look at a fly
away to fun I know like he's like I
dropped him up but yeah do it he dropped
us off and then I feel kind of flat in
the airport
I got a flag with that food now full
state even what day I will go to week
yeah so family reunion yeah so I guess I
think the situation that happened you
know you know skinny white boy hanging
out you know with his oversized Jersey
you know how shoes chance black family
leaving
he just cheerleading what you doing
nothing
you want to come with us can i sure how
about in is there room right so that
goes in with him the only white dude in
a family reunion and this food he was so
happy i bet but how much fun he had he
had to post a video rug so he put that
camera on and he kept talking about how
much fun it was he goes man I never have
been to a party where I had to ask who
made the potato salad oh good it was dog
and then he goes how talking about he
goes man I was dancing it could be a
damn floor I was looking the wall was
two big black asses they were like
rubbing up against me and I met and I
played dominoes spades I hung out the
old man pops I mean he said boy you walk
him with this house any time you could
you put a be here next year tell my
phone number if you're any help you call
me man I didn't lie I must admit it
I've been calling that [ __ ]
every week
just last week I stroke path to the
hospital to get his medicine and [ __ ]
man
he kept actually how much fun he had dog
and didn't kill this guy but he never
won a race you don't they have no racism
in his blood but he just was he wasn't
the only white boy there he was having a
heart of a good time right anyway so
whatever this I'm reading the comments
everybody to hell yeah man everybody
every memory sure
Latinas Chinese people proto Rican
people Hindu people talking about the
last time they were they went to a party
and it was lit up then finding this
revolution your brother
Lisa comment see I stay awake
y'all don't see how much racism is
coming out that [ __ ] mouth oh my
god whatever right three whole [ __ ]
black people this guy said [ __ ]
you used to walk you sleepwalking he saw
what you sleepwalking a crackhead it was
hilarious dog the way they beat that for
broke but that's what's up exposure dog
yeah man so man it takes one to know one
yeah but it was funny man I have to tell
you the whole story about him just to
tell you how that for y'all guys hanging
woke the listener for big poster a photo
of a brother of big-ass ice [ __ ]
you sleepwalking you pick it up you be
able to really too many bumps
watch it too were YouTube you should go
our style smaller somebody [ __ ]
have some fun yeah have fun
no man magic dog if that fool wouldn't
not act that would have been standing
out there or you never have been invited
he would have been saint man he would be
home sad bro watching Fox News Alex
Jones Rush Limbaugh getting fed with
[ __ ] dog let me tell you when we
were kids my family and my dad were all
going to a party whatever and we saw
Tony woods or Tony or whatever 20 B or
whatever his name was he was taking out
with his [ __ ] fluffy shirt bro escape
Swiss [ __ ] um suede pants you know
just chillin no chillin he look at my
father we are going Chile
that's it we're gonna go to the park bro
have a barbecue with a family I'm gonna
place our baseball oh right just gonna
be beer there because my dad will be a
lot of beer ray then my dad left you
wanna come away fool that food came the
fool playing baseball with his dress
clothes dress shoes and his dress shirt
now he'll ready to go dancing but
playing softball my dad stole second and
third and one of the guy for the other
team was on third base be racing in
Spanish no children
even now he's black people they steal
everything game so you better watch home
plate yeah bad now fool hit the ball and
for that fool let go the bat when a bat
flew dog
and luckily didn't hit nobody man but no
was like a lot of funny racial jokes
being said about the bat being thrown
but yeah man Tony had a good time man
that's something you got a man this goes
out to everybody who listening man if
you were going somewhere to a party and
your neighbors out there you know your
neighbor oh you never speak - but you
just say hello to him or something again
don't even look at each other a man a
little common courtesy a man would you
like to come would you like to come over
to my house maybe not invite him to your
house party but it's better to invite
him to another house party before he
wants a [ __ ] neighbor every Friday
yeah like that like white dude broke
Holi pops every week you know problem
this door he'll be there every day yeah
man they adopted that fool who's that a
dude it was somewhere man in links to be
or maybe you follow that for now he'll
know his pose got a million views wanna
see it 25,000 likes you know and it's
all positive you know I mean people need
that in America you know people don't
know how to have fun they just feed you
that nasty [ __ ] on TV dude I got it I
went to our Filipino birthday party and
they were eating the exact same food
that Mexican
is but just more greasy weed-free do
these something with video but it's dry
with me in it on me big chunks of me and
a TA gross but what they were fools have
in it different twist different twist
okay enough for that get back to the
business at hand September 30 my HBO
special premieres at 10:00 p.m. 7 p.m.
on west coast also start streaming on
HBO GO HBO now and the next day October
6 & 7 Nashville Tennessee attend and
Amy's October 8th Huntsville Alabama a
stand-up live one night only one night
only
October 12th to the 14th Edmonton
Alberta Canada at the comic strip
you're a passport bro yeah I got a class
where people don't fly and go to where
I'm Canada [ __ ] yeah dude that's call me
an $1,800 flight oh geez I can't you
should open your mother now I'm gonna
answer that come on ma that's too
expensive for him saw the watch okay
nevermind she don't know yeah bro
the other day the battle get up there
still waiting on that oh yeah yeah I got
a passport though but I can't spend 1800
on a flight surely I can get it for less
than that you can stop t-shirt room make
it all back all right here the gentlemen
October 20th San Diego and home fries by
the bay I know for all your listening no
guests my dog October 21st
Reno Nevada at Silver Legacy Casino but
I will see you at the show frogs you
know you're gonna be there
we're gonna hang out again anyway so
October 26 Phoenix Arizona I stand up
live but check this out we're doing the
ark things comedy live podcast festival
not a regular stand-up show this is for
the our teens comedy podcast first of
all during doing a live
Google doing alive what's so full
podcast and I'll be doing a short set
I'm one of the stand-up shows they'll be
putting together that night check out
Philippe is world.com slash tour for all
the show dates for the rest of the year
ladies and gentlemen ok shoutouts Toto
to you Toto to your who saw at the brain
improv and wanted a shout-out Toto to
you Miguel
Koo who had a trip booked for last week
in Orlando and was going to seal perform
but everything was canceled because of
the hurricane he's in Denver so he might
be going to my boulder show once that
gets scheduled he was gonna go all the
way from Denver to Orlando to see the
show
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome and vacation
of course go to Disneyland okay all
right but then he had to cancel it yeah
that sucks
shoutout to all the people who gave us
and I turned review iTunes review Alfred
J Garcia you kept it 100 e-pawn say 100
Rafa 20 Rafa's D 2 to 1 100 big fern in
the a tou chapter 100 to 80 Oh Jose Tony
you kept a $50 I'm just kidding kept the
100 or Carlos ideas Tyler ideas the
[ __ ] last name is socks
he kept a $100 our charcoal 14 Suarez
each c-17 Marco guitar he plays guitar
for la Santa Cecilia we're trying to get
them on a partner before they get too
big time for us like a Chicano Batman so
what stuff whoa you got kept in 100 big
BG 1080 mugs 3-1 no Carlos brings a
bringing us aka the plexi cam 15 earned
out 15 Sugo fee subo t RG r 5000 keeping
it 100
then our hit s o X X Y Brown 9 1 5 Joe
Avila Mike Marie de Jesse and the city
of Ontario
chessy chiana's Big Daddy sees mad gecko
man who says he listens every week from
Swank Quinton orderly people know you
locked up xxx blood - bad xxx no double
legs bloodbath double legs fury is 99
monkey cat buffalo 26 dark one seven
three five five JD
Hank - 3 6 9 + ro 4 1 9 9 Miguel be four
nine nine four big o hm7 you guys kept a
100 man thank you very much for doing
that for us you guys did it man you got
kept in 104 us but we need a thousand
are you guys now to keep it 1000 so
what's up man power jig is called in
last week - torch yeah last week to
promote the the pitch I want to go see
it
oh yeah I'm gonna see tomorrow Orlando
got cancelled so I had no choice I had
to go how was it oh man it was [ __ ]
funny fool I seen the hole though there
was a lot of people at the show bro a
lot of people didn't know I like it I
love the gap of blood in blood out was
there which one Sal lopizzo barricade me
was there and the guy from blood in
blood out he wasn't one of the guys from
the now onda him and brother were the
one that were studying drugs with the a
beers and then they last her their
backup and in one of them he got stabbed
by the by the black guerrilla family
he's the one that was hanging upside
down and his brother got killed at st.
Mary's the lurmen
at st. Mary's Church anyway those two
guys one of the guys was there at the
show our man John Savage was there
really cool yeah he's good friends with
um was Mike Gomez
leads bro please dawg yes lead shoutout
to a zone
shout-out to a zone for going to see the
play
bro that want to go play he was willing
to play by himself bro he will use it a
night no the next day okay
annihilated bro taking a photo without
Mike Gomez that fool said just saw this
play with poetry is a [ __ ] very funny
got to kick it with a homie right here
you have might know him from The Big
Lebowski leads hell yeah and then it was
there writing comments yeah man they
gotta work in his shifts you seen a Big
Lebowski yeah no cop which cop in The
Big Lebowski they're down he sees the
cops two times one time when he gets a
car back and they peed on it a couple of
vagrants did you did for a hotel room
yeah you're gonna find these guys
everybody leaves in a car go leads yeah
I just called a crime lab where they got
out the other two more detectives to
this case
I got a working late shift so here Paul
Rodriguez a kid that plays pierot junior
and his other pappu here's to the
professional yeah remember the first day
on Leon yeah this guy he doesn't kill
they're calling him up what's tomorrow
yeah - a guy out here how does he look
serious he stabbed that guy then he they
talked to a real real fat guy and he
goes hey so you're back in town huh what
are you gonna do
are you gonna leave yeah go back our
friend on the phone then Leon gets on
the phone you got the message
yeah then that the guy with the glasses
a fat guy he's an actor he didn't um the
page also he plays like a fat producer
that's that's one of my brother's
favorite movies weathering the storm
he's back in Florida
I think he's got no power right now the
profession was bad you know how many
times I've written the sequel to that
will be my head the sequel the
professional bro but merely said they
did our research trying to find our body
and I think the person who owns the
rights
the story is not allowing nobody to do
another story really that's why they
haven't done see yeah there's a lot of
fights they wanted to make one before
cuz my my idea worse here it is
Daniel yellow right he's holding the
money for the little girl that Leon left
behind that's the other movie ends so
it's my thing she goes ask for that
money he don't have it so then he gets
killed now Natalie Portman had to find
out who killed that [ __ ] should
she be friends the people that he's to
work for to work for them and start
doing our murder for them just to get to
the main guy who's in Naples bro working
for the Camorra Daniel deep dog get that
cheese back and it is called Matilda and
that called a professional you know we
could just no we don't have to use the
professional name the buiiet just called
Matilda and the [ __ ] trailer is a
plant a glass of milk and I hate K dog
cuz it was the original tell Leon the
professional yeah Lea I'm the
professional have you guys ever seen the
Unrated it rated X version of it
the French released not to the American
people no no I didn't even realize the
thing he falls in love with her dude in
the movie I kind of had a fear that's
going on what and the French version the
original version you could see it more
bro is create be that over there oh yeah
cultural norm out there yeah cuz there's
a scene where when she was and they
don't see an American version when she's
checking in she's talking she's all like
off Lucy bro Jovi are all happy and then
she goes is that your father no he's my
husband
Wow yeah there was definitely like a
banner like almost like creepy vibe
between the two of them so worse three
go Toor is right here to the right of me
we got Adam Murray here getting ready
for San Jose
yeah man curl he's doing the touristy
he's doing stuff here in California that
comedians never do like be our
background gas and the Conan O'Brien
show comedian in in California I've been
living here in five years ten years that
were ever ever in his life going the
audience of any television show when
you're a tourist what do [ __ ] around get
spotted on like I return I get paid
remember dog bro we had a friend Ivan he
to get paid $100 to sit in the audience
that's awesome yeah that's way better
than Oberon and F will quit the only
lasted a day or two oh that's a day dog
you bought you clothes and everything
huh and then he went to Tel BOTS do you
feel man when you're in the audience and
be honest okay they're gonna grab you
bro and tell you the comedian cancer can
do we knew so no it's never gonna happen
no I did I did I did the dance like they
had a dance contest for the warm-up and
the I know the warm-up guys so he chose
me to come down there and dance and yeah
I just I went all crazy and like ripped
my shirt off and through the crowd and
it threw it back it was fun man it was a
ton of fun I mean how often you're gonna
be on that stage so I figured you know
go all out
here it no no of course we're doing the
fool what do you make it our warmest jar
be easier for here bro
his job is to warm up people he shot
these are you there [ __ ] shut up I
skinned my knees and not for suing the
thing the stage has these big wooden
panels and there's like a gap I slid on
my knees you ask where's craft service
for smoking weed or nothing and this guy
dude what my buddies told me when I did
it with like when I I ripped off my
shirt and threw into the crowd you do it
again I got a dude a dude with an
earpiece that came from behind the
curtain like shits about to go down like
he wanted to be ready and though I
posted a photo of like dancing you can
see the guy that came out from behind
the curtain like standing there at the
ready lake in case I'm insane or
whatever I mean I guess well it'll know
you I could see it wrong yeah over here
[Laughter]
rip that curl off the horse of death not
a little kid dog dude I mean come on
excited man yeah man what did you win a
t-shirt
[Laughter]
so that cool vanity yeah it's it's a
t-shirt that says Conan and then part of
it in is like blacked out it says
audience when you can only get it if
you're one of the people chosen to go
down there
Wow so it leaves it all scraped yeah oh
wow
battle wounds over here yeah ours got
rug burns piping man I get it but what
happened it was a ton of fun man there I
found out I found out last night like
what I went to the Improv to watch
comics and there was a dude there was
like dude you're the dude who [ __ ]
ripped off your shirt and Conan turns
out like at while I was down there
dancing the warm-up dude grab this old
lady and sent her over to me to like
dance with me I didn't realize she was
an old lady shouldn't look like an old
lady because all I saw was her from the
back like bumping towards me and it
turns out that was the mom of the comic
that was performing on the show on the
Conan show on the Conan show floor ah
Jenn easy like I don't remember what her
les yeah yeah she did great dude she's
got a standing ovation it was amazing
she did really well hurt the name of her
album is like jay-z's new album there's
wow yeah she did great man but like the
I just like the fact that it's such a
small world to run into someone the net
like the next day at The Improv going
you're the dude who ripped off your
[ __ ] shirt it coded that was my
friend's mom you were dancing with like
the the Chancellor that are like a
million to one I feel like wow you broke
through I guess it was fun man there was
there like a bunch of people there was
like three or four different groups of
people afterwards like high-five a mango
know was great I mean I don't people
liked it I definitely made a fool of
myself more jelly
it was fun man I had a out of last it's
all the matters hell yeah for a bad
somebody'll come out you walk into the
room right now bro
we'll give you our five dollars yes snip
those curls off right now awful five
hundred dollars a year of rent free in
LA one of those [ __ ] scissors that
[Laughter]
with my fingers have it all bleeding ah
judicial won't stop bleeding let you go
to the doctor dog hey Warren bro
a year and free in LA there's there's a
lot of [ __ ] people would do for that
yeah man so when so you left though you
left Orlando before the storm did you
have a hard time leaving with a lobby
with the airport dude yeah okay when I
landed cuz I hit up the manager of the
improv because I was in Vegas I hit him
up before I hit her up before we before
I flew asking if the shows are still
going on cuz at the time it looked like
the end of days like it was the biggest
hurricane ever there's a category five
and I was like there's no way because I
knew if you came and we'd even if we did
Friday and Saturday Thursday Friday
Saturday you're not gonna be able to
leave look there's no way so I hit her
up and she's like I we don't know yet so
I was like alright so I flew in the
moment I'll and I got text from Lisa and
from her going hey shows cancelled not
like [ __ ] I was like my thought process
was if if I don't get out now even if
it's not bad I might not be able to go
to San Jose and I didn't want to miss
San Jose so I thought at worst I'm gonna
be couch surfing in LA for a week
instead of sitting at home without power
seems worth it to me so
I started trying to book a flight and
the flights had like immediately shot up
like seventeen hundred three thousand
dollars and I'm like what the [ __ ]
wow so crisper so well there's kid and
then that really happened yeah dude and
I was like [ __ ] well step it was like
300 or 400 they check back 20 min later
it was like 18 loggers dude it was like
it was so [ __ ] expensive they're like
all the Southwest flights were like six
seven hundred bucks and those those are
normally cheap so I searched I just
started googling and like all the delta
flights that were like 200 bucks I was
trying to book those because originally
I was I was trying to I was gonna
reschedule the one cuz I was you guys
had already had a flight for me out to
San Jose
I was gonna try to reschedule it but the
cost to do that it's like 200 bucks but
they were a lot of airlines were
dropping that fee because of the
hurricane but then I looked and I found
one like when I tried to book one of the
ones that were like 200 bucks
by the time I'd go through it it was
like hey we don't have that flight
anymore
like he couldn't go through the process
I was it did I I got ended up getting
one on an American for like 186 bucks
really what the lady say are you that
guy from Conan I just I just booked it
online I was like you know what 186
bucks is worth a gamble because if it is
if it is as bad as there were projecting
at the time then I'd rather not be there
so how's the airport dog dude
there was a line to get to the line to
wait for TSA it was like a block-long of
just waiting to get into the line that
was already huge to get through TSA how
about TSA approved oh the the the
pre-checker whatever I ended up getting
into that line cuz I was waiting and
there was no one in the pre-check and I
happened to be like right at the right
part of like the little carousel wine D
thing damn and they were just like hey
come through this line I was like [ __ ]
yeah let's take off my shoes or anything
how long will the line the table it
honestly maybe half an hour like I got
there I got there probably two hours
before my flight because I'm like I know
it's gonna be crazy and it was like it
was I have never seen the airport that
busy there were people just like camping
out in the airport
hoping to leave like that oh they had
gotten through security some
and they were just waiting to try to fly
standby or whatever every single spot
you could possibly imagine people were
just sitting and waiting like they were
it it like although all the roads I had
people who tried to drive out and it
took that there were comics that were
trying to get to a different part of the
states do a show and they couldn't get
there cuz like they were just sitting
traffic and move like a block and a half
an hour
they were just that many people trying
to leave damn it was it was crazy man
like there were people there were people
running out of gas because gas stations
didn't have gas you know they were like
everyone filled up their cars so they're
paranoid about it it was there there was
so much paranoia about it like I feel
like the media hyped it up so much that
people were losing their goddamn mind
they were so I mean that they started
selling water for like 40 bucks or
whatever like they were doing in Texas
but the thing hit people get mad at that
bro they get mad at that just because
somebody decides to stop water enough of
$40 like he can make a profit it's
called capitalism doc yeah you didn't
get mad at that guy but you know but
we're here not open arms and getting in
line and protesting about doubts are
doing that [ __ ] to the airline tickets
why is it okay for an airline to charge
$1,000 extra for a ticket but a guy that
trying to make 40 bucks up a gallon of
water
it's a criminal they ended up capping
all the the airlines all caps or charges
like JetBlue I think didn't charge
anything higher than like a hundred
bucks or something for their tickets
they capped all their tickets at some
point because they were getting crazy
like I was looking to go on the the
flights went from literally
instantaneously from like 200 bucks to
like seventeen hundred three grand
it was and those weren't those were like
sitting in the and the ass end of the
plane like they weren't like the
first-class demand man I wish we knew we
knew somebody that was at the Greyhound
station oh that must have been yeah I
mean I don't know how they would they
wouldn't have they would have been stuck
in traffic like everyone else like when
you look at that we look at the map of
Florida like this one oh I'm wrong right
I'm like Google like i-75 was just read
the whole
way from from Orlando all the way up was
just Jacksonville yeah Jacksonville got
well that was the thing as they declared
a state of emergency and then they had
all these mandatory evacuations and
Jacksonville was one of the places that
had a Jacksonville Beach was like
mandatory evacuations so everyone from
Jacksonville was trying to take like a
10 or 95 just stop you're born and
raised in Orlando no I was born in Fort
Lauderdale I was born and raised in Fort
Lauderdale and West Palm like it was a
high school in West Palm this is the
craziest [ __ ] that you ever seen
anything related to a storm or hurricane
no I don't know man
well here's the thing is because like a
lot of people who were born there don't
give a [ __ ] like they're like other than
Daisy at all huh yeah I mean the only
other storm I've evacuated for was
Andrew so this is the first storm since
Andrew dog this is the first storm since
Andrew that I wasn't in the state for
that I was like I probably shouldn't do
that I mean I I've gone to like like
when I was living in a trailer I went to
someone else's house and the trailer got
[ __ ] up but it was like I mean you go
to a better structure but you know you
don't leave this thing most people just
go buy some beer it's like a snow day
but in floor have hurricane parties
right yeah yeah it's just an excuse to
drink and like basically what happens is
when you live there you buy a bunch of
canned food and a bunch of water and
then it ends up being way less and you
think it's gonna be and then you go
alright well [ __ ] I got a pile of water
sitting in the corner and a bunch of
canned food I'm never gonna eat that's
the crazy thing is people buy [ __ ] they
never like every other day of the week
they're drinking a bunch of soda yeah
and then when the hurricane comes I
gotta have water it's like you you drink
soda every other day of the year and now
you gotta hydrate you shut the [ __ ] up
you just get whatever the hell you
normally worry about the president
apples now what's the price on macadamia
just buy [ __ ] junk snack food and
then you eat you eat stuff that you
wouldn't wanna or you wouldn't have to
cook like Chef Boyardee and which is
gonna not be the great
look the cat exactly that's what you do
you get a bunch of that [ __ ] and then
you just hope for the best but like all
my friends are sitting at home without
power which sucks there because you were
so hot it's so hot limit and then you
other you can't take a hot shower
because the water heater did enough
power so it's like I you know but yeah
it's like I saw stuff like there's
there's a lot of places we're flooding a
buddy of mine lives in an apartment
complex there's a bunch of trees and all
the trees felt like one fell into one of
the apartments and a bunch of cars got
crushed there's so there's a lot of a
lot of stuff like that where trees just
come down I saw a picture we're like one
of the giant cement power line poles was
like ripped in half so I mean there is
stuff like that that even in Orlando
that went crazy but I hear like the keys
dude in Miami right I saw I don't know
if you saw pictures and video we're like
the right before it hit it sucked all
the water out of like Tampa yeah and the
keys people were just walking on the on
the Cuban walking into Miami they were
they were just walking on the on the on
the ocean bed like it's just seeing the
Irie man
you know back hard yeah you're not gonna
be able to run away from that if it came
back that's I mean when I'm when they
show the that big ol tsunami on the
field Haiti or Japan Thailand
oh the Tahiti one yeah
Tahiti I don't know which one it was out
the vacation spot people were hanging
now like you said they were angry now in
the fishing and then all the water left
and the bowls were on the ground yeah so
then you see like a little bit of water
come but it kept coming and kept coming
it kept coming yeah followed by a wave
dog cuz the videos that you see are from
a dude with hotels that are way yeah dog
in the water still eat that did you see
the one we're like the I want to say was
the the tsunami in Japan where they
showed like like a parking lot full of
cars and all the cars just got crushed
and started swirling they started
swirling around like Cheerios and
toilet like just [ __ ] getting crushed
and shoved to the side and stuff and
it's like that I don't know how you can
walk out and that that Beach for that
bear thing not thinking about if that
wave came crashing it maybe that's the
rush maybe they're doing it cuz they're
like hell yeah I could die right now
maybe I don't know but I don't if you're
not thinking about that I don't know how
you could possibly not think about that
like just walking out knowing if that if
it that storm surge hit right then
you're gonna be crushed I saw some
videos I don't know faked in Houston
Texas those those are people in the
living room there was chasing a fish
either guy that catches it yeah I seen
that one I think that's just true dog
but um I saw the photos of Miami you
know that Street in um salt in South
Beach they were right next to where a
rocket way around
scarf it was shot I don't you I saw that
all that she is sand well dude they said
in Miami dude in the streets there's
sharks in the water dog yeah dude I
tried to get my parents to evacuate
because they were in the catastrophic
zone like the part that was supposed to
just be just decimated yet crushed and
my dad's like I got shudders my dad has
these crazy shudders people have like
shudders where they have to like go put
them up he's got like electric ones that
are up all year and you just hey you
know who had shudders at Dougie points
house yeah they just push the button
they went down yeah his are like they
like accordion style like they just they
come out of the way and they're like
kind of hidden yeah and then it hits a
button they go like ran and just closed
did they work oh yeah yeah I mean I
talked to him he's fine he's okay I'm
cool I mean that dude I feel like I
don't know I feel like in in in at this
age he's like yeah whatever if it
happens it happens
like I feel like he didn't want to try
to make the drive like he could have
gone to his
to family unlike the Carolinas and
here's just like yeah [ __ ] it
I'm gonna stay here roll the dice like
he's he's at that age where he's like
yeah it's worth the risk
he would rather not be inconvenienced
with driving no [ __ ] the cousin no [ __ ]
he was like if it happens it happens
like that's pretty much where he's at so
all that shit's done with now the
hurricane over there I mean he he he he
gambled anyone like the yeah the
hurricane went through Georgia I think
yesterday I just think about all the
people that want to get high bro and how
much expensive drugs all right now I
imagine the fool that has a mad stash
fool I was reading their dog a buddy of
mine who a buddy of mine who evacuated
it had the same he had the same traffic
trouble trying to get back cuz everyone
who evacuated went to come back at the
same time I guess so it was like the
same horrible traffic like hours and
hours together on your drive coming back
how about those people men that that
that I went to these shelters like in
Houston or Florida and when it starts
checking Aidid they have warrants they
got arrested my bro they were to catch
you sooner or later dawg yeah there was
a well there's a guy in uh in like
Lakeland or something he never met a
race dog he put it out he put it out on
on social media I go to get whit if you
if you come to a shelter and you have a
warrant we're gonna arrest you but
here's the thing that's just gonna make
people who have stupid warrants for like
you know not paying a parking ticket
risk their lives to not go to the
shelter I think that's ignorant you got
to show your ID yeah yeah yeah yeah they
check you as you're walking in what
happens if you if you find it like if
that's the way you find out it you got a
warrant like you show up like all right
yeah whatever and they're like where's
your team into a dry please now dude why
don't one of my ex easy guard watch it
you know fools in jail can't stop
talking dog oh do you how about those
people are locked up in flood zones dude
that's there's water
shut up Gomez with the billy club you
know as [ __ ] goes down and a
the guards are gone well dude there's
some [ __ ] like that going down in
Texas know where they had them relocate
them and all types of [ __ ] but isn't
Texas crazier because they never go
through hurricanes and all that [ __ ]
Florida but I heard they laid out the
levee over there like though the dam was
getting too much or getting too much
water that's good to release water out
yeah they flooded those neighborhoods or
whatever I don't know I don't talk about
to the people while we're about the
house they told me I don't need flood
insurance yeah I had a buddy of mine he
just moved into a house like right
before the hurricane hit and the
hurricane like started to tear the roof
off his garage and because it was a
named storm it's not the same type of
insurance it's hurricane insurance and
his deductibles like five grand and he
moved into it literally days before the
hurricane hit what does that mean it
means he's out like he's liable for at
minimum five grand so he can't he can't
have insured because the Hokie another
name no because because because it's a
name storm because it's a hurricane you
have to have hurricane insurance and the
hurricane insurance is a different
deductible and covers different [ __ ]
then what normal the normal like if you
if you're your normal house home
insurance would cover like like say
lightning strike yeah or a name
hurricane that doesn't have all that
hype
right right right like if it's just if
you just happen to have a storm and a
tornado hits and rips up your house that
would be natural disaster or whatever
just the fact that it's category 5 it
has a name now your [ __ ] deductible
jumps to 5 G's yeah instead of yeah
instead of like whatever it was like a
thousand or 500 or whatever now it's
like five grand and he literally just
moved in like he had he bright before
the storm was supposed to hit he like
posted a picture like I got all my boxes
and [ __ ] inside and then the storm
[ __ ] just dude he said it had a bunch
of water damage and stuff at saks man
that absolutely sucks like literally
have just moved in your house is
destroyed I mean it's not destroyed but
I'm certain it's all [ __ ] up it's a
weed situation out there it's not as
good as here like holy [ __ ] no with the
Hawker hurricane [ __ ] oh I don't know I
I heard anything about that I mean I
assume it's business as normal
maybe with no electricity no power all
you have a bottle waters a bunch of weed
pipes with no weed
oh you spoke at resin dawg it's gotta be
it's gotta be human as hell now cuz
there's all that standing water
everywhere and it's still gonna be hot
it's probably like 98 degrees 100
degrees there right now and you never
been through a hurricane of that kind of
glow you were little like oneno oh yeah
dude I mean not a category 5 a category
5 hasn't come through since since before
since Andrew Andrew was a category 5 but
it was smaller but like that's part of
the reason I like Orlando is they're so
weak by the time I get there like it
Charlie was the last one that came
through [ __ ] up Orlando but they
changed a lot of the arleigh they
changed a lot of the building codes
after Andrew so all the stuff in like
South Florida is much more resilient to
hurricanes because that was part Lily
that was part of the problem with Andrew
is the building codes were kind of [ __ ]
before Andrew and it just ripped all the
houses of partly they were built kind of
like all wood and stuff instead of like
concrete block and then you know
stronger Roos it took like neighborhoods
were leveled I get look it looked like a
party storm is being he evacuated after
all that a gentleman I'm a national
treasure a fool so bein broke what's up
with the fools that were shooting at the
storm dog I saw that they yeah they put
out they put out - stop it dog yeah they
put out news articles like don't shoot
at the storm pistol rifles whatever they
wanted to see if the bullet would curve
or whatever but they seemed like if you
shoot at that storm it's gonna bring you
back faster and hit your ass dog that's
Florida man diagrams on Twitter and all
that [ __ ] fool that's that's for
Buster's bro hackers
I mean especially once you go outside
any major city in Florida you run into
just some of the craziest rednecks like
any major city you go like 15 20 minutes
outside it it's just boom town like it's
just people with airboats and giant
trucks and everyone dude it's it's fun
man what that was read [ __ ]
[ __ ] Emillio life oh man I just
met a dude here that I was like holy
crap there was there was a guy and uh at
an open mic the other day that was like
missing a tooth it was like talking with
a real strong accents that was they are
this guy seems like he's from like
Kentucky or something
but no no I mean there was a UH there's
a there's a place I did stand-up in
that's an outdoor biker bar slash tattoo
parlor slash harley-davidson repair shop
and it's full of do Daytona it's in
Crystal River and it's like yeah I talk
about at my acronym it's that that place
is all red Nike like there how about
that place where that old man told you
not to give you one of those bumps oh
yeah that was it was a place called old
town tell us the story oh man I don't
know how to okay it was a place called
Old Town which there's a place close to
Orlando called that but apparently that
wasn't it and whoever this Booker is he
does that knowing that all the comics
and there you go oh yeah old towns not
far and then you find out it's on the
other side of the state like when you
look up the the address say with
everybody's there's redneck but only the
urban guys do well dude no way that's
that's uh that's Ricky that's crystal
river this place it was a this place
this place was like a lodge you know we
go there and it's like all these old
no the news large yeah it's exactly what
it was like doing with the elves dude it
was yeah I was like an alkalis or
something like that but it's in the
middle of middle of [ __ ] nowhere and
they don't have a microphone they don't
have lights a ton of a stage and it's
just blood filled it's in a little tiny
cafeteria and we go up there to do our
set and there was a part of my set for
those of you haven't seen it I like fist
pump a dude and do like a jellyfish
thing and do I do this other stuff but I
go to do the first one this is old man
sitting there wearing his like Korean
war hat and [ __ ]
and I go to fist bump him and he looks
at my fists and disgust and looks back
at me and goes I dunno goddamn drops a
hard end bum bump and I was like what
the [ __ ] and my friend from the backs
like what do you say and I repeated it
and they all laughed and I was like is
this about to become a trump rally and
they cheered and from then then they
started chanting n-word bump and word
bump n-word bump like they were calling
me the N word bump like that was my name
from then on it was it was a scariest
[ __ ] thing I've ever knew bumper well
I'm picture-picture this it's a long
room I'm standing at the back of it
facing a local the doors on the other
side exists taste lifts and it's like
I'm in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere on
a dirt road talking all these racists
that now they're they started to get
hostile towards me and I'm like this is
[ __ ] it was a scary should have ever
done and stand up and the the Booker got
mad at us cuz we didn't do like I didn't
want to like I was pretty much done at
that point and that's like just a couple
minutes in the most lady I was I was
going there to feature for my buddy
who's headlining he didn't do a bunch of
time either and I think between the two
of us we did maybe 30 or 40 minutes and
we're supposed to be there for an hour
and the guy got mad and they wouldn't
pay it so it's like dude they're yelling
[ __ ] racial slurs at us like who's
who's gonna do well in a venue like that
gonna be black people there no of course
not no
you shouldn't mean oh dude they were
hardcore that's the thing about racists
like people talk about racism ziz like
like it there they're quiet about it and
they hide it every racist I've ever run
into they're [ __ ] proud of it like
they think they've got the key to
success like you you know right you know
what am i yeah like their thirst super
proud of [ __ ] those people man it was
like that's that's that's pretty mania
paid dude I mean I was just happy to get
the [ __ ] out of there but it was like I
couldn't believe that people like that
exist but at the same time those people
never leave that part of their time
course dude that's I don't know them all
the they're the only thing they know or
what they hear from you know uncle Ted
lives up the street so that just breeds
that ignorance and they never leave so
they never interact with people like
that so they just they're like well I
was told that the you know what whoever
the [ __ ] is a horrible person
I've never seen otherwise so that's what
I know that's the only thing that makes
sense to me as those people never
interact with anything outside of their
little [ __ ] town like everyone knew
each other like when we asked him about
getting a microphone they're like oh we
can call Edie he owns the [ __ ] you
know whatever the mic shop yeah whatever
we could try to get one fueled the way
to check it was it was horrifying
it was absolutely [ __ ] horrified the
food was a bit horrible there - yeah
yeah all they had was like they had like
cheese and crackers and like trail mix
that with the audience white trash net
some thing yeah they had one one
waitress who was like you could tell she
was probably hot like 30 years ago and
she's just worked in that little bar her
entire life or something [ __ ] to it to
the bottom in that town dude I feel bad
for the people who live there like not
only are they trapped in that [ __ ]
ignorance but they're never gonna go
anywhere then I'm gonna do anything
they're never gonna you know what I mean
and um this is the kind of challenge
that big corporation can come in and
start moving any more [ __ ] out and
any bit minorities I guess I don't know
yeah I mean those people that they're
gonna be mad at people they're gonna
find a [ __ ] way to be mad at him
but the only my had the main person it
was we don't even understand those
concepts for it was how high do the hats
would go to seventh grade I don't know
man I didn't see a school out there I
don't I don't know if they're all home
school or a school watch rush
dude it was it was you corroborate that
- right you used to be like a truck
driver I was stepfather beat you in a
bear no Maya when I was when I was when
I was younger when I was like four four
or five my stepdad was a truck driver my
mom married him cuz it was the only guy
that my dad was afraid of that she ever
saw my dad was afraid of and he used to
take me on the road with him so my mom
wouldn't leave him while he was gone so
I was just like a blanket yeah yeah I
was like four or five and I was just
gone I was sleeping the sleeper he would
take me to truck stops and have me like
smoke cigarettes and drink coffee
because he the waitress just thought it
was cute so you've been smoking serum
five I was like I was like four smoking
cigarettes and I think that's why my
lungs are all [ __ ] up now for cheating
with cheating with Al Bundy and I'm we
touch what the waitress is all thought
it was adorable like I was a little kid
that that drank coffee I was drinking
yeah I would drink it I would I would
get ice I get a cup of ice and dump it
in there and add cream creamer and sugar
I'd add creamer and sugar to it when
it's hot cause it wouldn't dilute like
the sugar won't dilute when it's cold
and then I'd dump it in the ice this was
that abusive guy yeah yeah yeah yeah he
he beat the [ __ ] out of me why the only
four okay I'll give it I'll give you a
great example uh correct come on I think
I was like three I used to worry that he
would show up to shows like that was
that was a fear of mine that he would
somehow he showed three you see a guy
pointing pointing pointing [ __ ] palm
are cigarettes and a coffee full of
thermal he's a drinker [ __ ] be
he used to smoke Marlboros marble
yeah he did Marvel Reds here breath too
Winston's not thinking about people who
didn't smoke [ __ ] a marble a step
stepbrother Obama to this day if I get
the wrong with four cigarettes I go
under like a coughing fit and I can
vomit like it's the wrong the wrong
smell of a secret to make me vomit
almost instantaneously well cigarette
smokers never believe it until they see
it happen like I know why why would this
guy hit you
okay so like I remember well I would hit
you didn't like you I don't I don't
[ __ ] know I look like your dad I
remember I remember I think he was just
freshman I don't think he wanted kids if
I'm honest I think I think you're just
frustrated with the fact that he was
dealing with kids you got Pierce you
switch to Sanka
I remember one I remember ones of
Maxwell House house one morning I woke
up and I had [ __ ] my pants and in my
sleep I was three and I knew [ __ ] laughs
I don't know I was three man I [ __ ] my
pants when I was sleeping I woke up
knowing memory I knew immediately I was
gonna be in trouble
and he walked in to wake me up and knew
and me that [ __ ] man that little one
yeah yeah he went to wake me up and some
elements and then he he picked me up and
started shaking me be like why the [ __ ]
you shoot your pants and then he grabbed
me by this arm my left arm my left leg
and swung me around the room letting my
body hit like the dresser and everything
around the room yelling at me and like
the tumbler dragging it out through a
building dude and then he threw me
against the wall above my bed and I fell
into my bed and he left the room where's
your brother at on the other side of the
room watch what happened my dad my dad
tried to get me taken away from him and
we ended up going to a mediator so that
was that the bed throwing thing was
before we moved to Pensacola yeah my mom
was getting
beat up - oh so we went to holy Willy we
went to Pensacola and my dad tried to
get like an injunction to get us taken
away so he could get custody of us and
there was this guy named Gary poodle off
who was our mediator
we had to go talk to a mediator and I
still remember the guys name because
what he did he took us into a room mind
you this dude my stepdad was a huge guy
always he always had a big knife on his
side and we sat in this room I was
sitting right next to my brother Lord -
my brother was there - I'm sitting on
the floor
you're dead there - my stepdad is right
next to me he's closer to me than you
are right now viateur there - why
mediators there - why me been there
that's my dad was my dad was in the
courthouse he wasn't in that room might
have been in there but the stepdad
shouldn't have been in there no cuz
right then the guy asked me if he if he
beats us or brought over here in front
of him so I look at him and look down
the floor in the mediator didn't see
that's going on yeah back there man the
back Hobbs a teacher was all [ __ ] it
stupid they say if you show up with a
burn arm and your teacher see the burn
arm the cop shows that the principal
shows up they didn't get your mom did
your mommy do that to you
they [ __ ] scared ya there's so many
times I said no to my my little bruise
in front of people my hand were ask me
my grandma asked me do about that did
you do that if I just said yes I
wouldn't have made it out of that car no
there's no [ __ ] away Howard like
never woulda beat you in mr. poodle do
it yeah he would have take him like
you're talking about a a cokehead truck
driver that like like he's good like I'm
he's gonna go down cuz of me I'm sure
I'm sure the laws are different now
floor yeah they've changed a lot of that
[ __ ] because like it doesn't stuff like
that happening like I mean now the least
your dad was trying though but [ __ ] I
woulda killed that [ __ ] yeah my
dad definitely I gotta hand it to him he
really liked that that was look
hindsight being 20/20 he [ __ ] did
exactly what he should have done I mean
I don't know I don't know if he should
have I mean it would have been outside
the law to like kidnap me basically like
take me in
just be like I'm not giving the kids
back cuz he knows what's going on like
he would have got in trouble for that
members you will not just that but I
know my mom enough to know that that
would have just been a source of
argument like even though she knew the
situation was bad she probably would
have been like now is my time to fight
with him because they just got remarried
my mom my dad so he said I'm due that
day and then what you wanted you he went
to jail for that no he never went to
jail yeah he he we after we left him we
ended up believing I'm my we just in the
middle of night I think we just got in
the car and just came back to Fort
Lauderdale
he ended up tracking us down later and
now everyone be no idea he well there
was a one time he tracked us down on
vacation we were at a hotel there's a
knock at the door we thought it was room
service and it was him fog I hadn't seen
him in years before getting it this time
I was in like middle school what'd he
have a coffee for you he was trying to
talk to my mom to take her back or
whatever I was just like dude I was
tired I was scared shitless
Oh your Sikhs no I wasn't like at that
point I was in like middle school are
you already tall no no I didn't get tall
till college it was about six there was
like a course of six months where I went
from being like five six to like six
three like my back hurt and I couldn't
figure out why am i my jeans were like
high waters I thought they were
shrinking in the and the emission in the
you know dryer dryer and I just I didn't
know I was tall so someone told me so
what the [ __ ] happened when he showed up
he he talked to my mom and I just
remember like standing there shaking
like holy [ __ ] I can't believe he's
[ __ ] here like I thought he was gone
forever
and then she said no and shut the door
arm or whatever and then like like a
month or two later he robbed her house
and stole everything what do you take
from you my mom had a badass like TV and
stereo system he stole all that he stole
all her jewelry
he stole anything of value in the house
because he went to buy drugs I guess
yeah
damn dad dude it was [ __ ] up how many
years did last day two or three were
they together
no this craziness I mean that was pretty
much the last we heard of him is after
he robbed the house
that's the last time I ever heard of him
but after that you were afraid and walk
into a showing [ __ ] you know for a long
time I thought about like I wasn't I'm
not afraid cuz I thought he's gonna [ __ ]
me up I'm I was afraid for a while
because I didn't know what I would do if
I if I saw him like for a long time I
thought about trying to hunt him down
for revenge and then I'm like that she
like that reminded oh yeah for a long
time I was like he's got to be old and
you [ __ ] feeble now and it's like he
picked on me because I couldn't defend
myself and now now now your turn now
could be reverse I thought about that
and I'm like the consequences of doing
something like that aren't [ __ ] worth
it like this is a piece of [ __ ] he could
be dead by now you know what I mean
like living the way he was looking back
he's probably dead by now but it was
like I thought about like what it would
be like like if he just ran we show up
to a show cuz I went and saw Gabriel and
he talked about his dad just [ __ ]
showing up to a show and it was like
that's that's been my fear as I started
you know like what happens if this guy
shows up I don't know if I'm gonna flip
out or what you know what I mean like I
don't even I don't even know if I would
recognize him
what if could we make you bring him for
you dude it was like I can remember like
I can see vividly what he looks like
from basically like the waist down or
chest now you know I never I don't I
didn't like looking him in the eye
I like I I didn't want to look him in
the eye because it was like I do I
didn't want to give him any reason to
like flip out and like hit me or
whatever you know what I mean like I
don't know man it was it was crazy it
was like living with someone who
basically wanted to kill you 24/7 which
is like even to this day when like
someone goes like that
I like jump a little bit and I think
that's probably that's gotta be what
it's from like just living for that long
with like someone who would just punch
you for no reason it's just it [ __ ]
with you man
the one of you a comedian bro I will say
man doing stand-up it was like it's a
release dude like it it it levels me out
just as much as like like when I was a
kid I used to watch stand-up and out was
my release and the moment I
figured out I could do that nothing else
mattered I was like I want to [ __ ]
just keep doing that because I know like
I remember doing a show in Daytona and
there was an officer who showed up after
the show he was like hey I'm an officer
and I see like [ __ ] that I'll never be
able to forget every day and you made me
forget about it for however long you're
onstage and I was like that's exactly
why I do this
oh yeah that's what we do stand-up
comedy like that like the moment I
figured out I could do it I was like
nothing now it's [ __ ] matters
so did you brother get here to the
affected by it he didn't get hit as much
like from my stepdad he didn't get hit
as much for whatever reason it was yeah
I really identified that you were little
yeah I really identify with that movie
Radio Flyer yeah because it was like the
little kid got the brunt of it and the
older child didn't get it as much and it
was like always I think I think what it
is is that guys have [ __ ] coward he's
a piece of [ __ ] coward and he went after
the little kid and the mom because those
were the defenseless ones and you were
like you were never even you're not even
in school yet when you were in the truck
right yeah yeah at the beginning when he
was doing it I that's the reason we
ended up I think that's probably the
reason we ended up being able to leave
is cuz he was gone I was in kindergarten
at that point and my mom just like
grabbed us only [ __ ] left so it's
like yeah that's probably why that
happened as I was in school at that
point I don't there's a lot of [ __ ] like
that I don't remember like there's whole
chunks to my memory that's just gone
like I remember him doing stuff like
kicking the dog we had little dog not
dad he kicked the dog hard enough that I
went flying and hit the sliding glass
door like the guy was a monster but you
know kicking a little dog people like
that exist are you ready what do to
anybody I don't remember what the dog
even did that that upset him
she'd his pants maybe [ __ ] on the carpet
I don't know he's got a thing for people
[ __ ] in places they shouldn't be I
guess I don't know man the guy was a it
was it's horrific dude like do you like
everyone you were like um have like like
are you shell-shocked
you have dreamed
that it happened it's happening again no
I mean nightmares pts I don't know that
I well it comes to me in ways like they
didn't let us talk to you about it when
you were a little kid not terribly help
to you we ended up doing family therapy
but we never got into that [ __ ] like
when for whatever reason that never came
up and I don't know why cuz definitely I
should have talked about it but like
things things happen like my memories
horrible because I think cuz I blocked
out so much that like there's there's a
for a long time there was stuff like I
couldn't remember stuff that happened
even recently because it was just like I
feel like I was blocking out so much of
my childhood that it was almost like I
wasn't making new memories and stuff at
some point wow that's crazy
it's like there's just so much of my for
whatever reason parts of my memory like
that don't work well just because I was
shutting it off for so long do you
remember that time you scared Sandra
Bullock yeah do they bother you now
though when a woman smokes are you with
her oh yeah I can't be with a chick I
dated one chick who smokes and I just
can't do it man hell no huh
did it well I mean aside from the fact
that it [ __ ] me up it's gross like it
stinks don't mind I don't mind pot like
pot I think smells good but good in the
bag or in there yeah but but tobacco
dude that's I don't understand what
people smoke cigarettes cause it's like
what do you get out of that like you're
not getting high I know man I've never
understood I've asked my change I've
asked several people and they say you
know it calms them down or whatever but
you know then it's nah I got a Mitchell
when that would get up early in the
morning or accomplished something you
know just do anything and then late at
night or a cup of coffee cigarette I
have to make me feel good when you when
I first met you you were smoking sheds
doing nothing I was smoking a cigarette
after I eat diet cokes but then I
thought then I'm when Edwin was smoking
it was someone Filipino comedian in Las
Vegas he would told me that he was
smoking a joint and then puff to a
cigarette like half of it then who feel
who feel higher and it felt good
when I did that one time I stopped doing
that man I don't wanna [ __ ] smoked
weed and crack after my just stick to
the crack tobacco but I noticed like I
don't know I don't know know these
stories but now I know why you you you
um you appreciate life more than other
people like taking a shirt off at that
hour
you like you you're something like you
blocked out a lot of your childhood but
it feels like you used to have a lot of
child into like you still want to have
fun yeah okay that never leaves my cuz
it was once that feeling of never
wanting to have fun leaves your park
dude you turned to that grumpy old
[ __ ] did I think that I keep the
curls going oh god I can't believe I'm
blanking on his name Robin Williams said
something like like you just have a
little bit of that childish nature in
you and once it's gone it's gone
you got to cherish it and keep it like I
enjoy that sometimes I act like a child
and that you know they have this
I like celebrating the little things you
know what I mean like like I celebrate
the fact that I got an audition because
I remember the time when I didn't get
auditions you know so it's like if some
if I if I booked it that's gravy but I
just love the fact that it's like [ __ ]
yeah got another audition and sometimes
the auditions come it's like I can't
believe the [ __ ] names that are
attached to him it's like holy hell like
if I get that I feel like that I'd be
with like winning the lottery you know
but it's like you know I got a little
shitty audition I got a dude I mean it's
not shitty I'm I don't know it's it's
not even named part it's like store
clerk but I don't care
I'm excited I get Holly's old I'm
excited that I get to you know do that I
know actors that are that are sitting
there that haven't had auditions in
months you know and they're like they
would have loved to have store clerk I'm
gonna bet you don't you're not a heavy
drinker Mac because I would hate to hear
those stories sobbing in a hotel room no
no that's alcohol's never been my thing
there was I went through a bad breakup
and I was drinking a bit for that that's
all I have are self men with nips yeah
yeah magician yeah
yeah that whole thing yeah yeah I guess
no one else knows I did it I'd almost
dating a chick all right and one day
we're we're all having a great time he
gets a car that no comedian no comedian
by the way this is just for comedians
want to hear I'm one here watching your
friend do stand-up he's funny yes we're
done okay I don't give a [ __ ] if you
ever slept with him I don't give a [ __ ]
about anything just the fact that you
call somebody else funnier through a
[ __ ] alligator we're done Bravo dumped
it right there yeah I mean hindsight is
20/20 I guess I don't know man yeah I
just
I've always known for a while that like
there's there's gonna be a girl who like
is gonna get the better of me that's
just I know it's a weakness
women are like a weakness to me I go I
don't know something about a pretty face
it's just like I overlooked a lot his
girlfriend she was pretty she's smoking
hot but she had like no elbows she has
no elbows and three fingers on each hand
yeah yeah but like you would never know
it I mean you meet her in person you
don't notice it at first until it's
pointed out and then some people that's
all they see I would like to you next
time you meet someone that that don't
point nothing out bro cuz I'm oh stop
staring but another thing will sure what
I don't know what that means I know
there was there was some drug or
something given the mother and it causes
a deformity or something that's what
happened yeah yeah yeah that's exactly
what happened
but the other thing I figured out cuz I
had to do a lot of self-reflection about
it was I I found that with my own family
what would happen is they like
especially with my brother he would do
something completely fucked-up to me
and then apologize I was like alright we
got to go back to being normal so I was
I was used to this ritual of people I
care about doing something completely
[ __ ] up to me and then apologizing and
that's you know acting like it's cool
and then moving on and so when she
started doing that to me it felt natural
do you know what I mean
yeah so it's like trying not to identify
with that and get stuck in a [ __ ] up
relationship just because that's what I
was used to growing up like i've
separated myself from my brother a
little bit because I found our
relationship is better if we're not you
know if we're not surrounded by each
other so much just because you know
there's some abrasiveness there that's
just I don't know his nature that's how
I feel about my family bro if I feel
once a year we're good assume I see him
way more than that like you know we live
in the same city you know I see him
probably a little more but why would you
hope you instead they're floating
somewhere right now bro I don't know
what I don't know what part of the
country he moved to I don't know I I
mean come on he was like doing coke and
[ __ ] way back then truck driving and
trucks revving that's gotta wear on yeah
he's kind of died of a heart attack by
now hemorrhoids something yeah there's
no I mean if if he's still alive he's
he's gotta be [ __ ] up I would be
surprised if he's not [ __ ] up he
should be a whiteness 60 70 though I
mean I don't know he was probably 40s
when I was a kid yes
late 30s something like that [ __ ]
ticker exploded on yeah I mean how often
can a body like take that kind of abuse
smoking cigarettes truck driver like
that I've always wanted to like figure
out a way to talk about on stage and
I've that I don't know I just I can't
detach myself from her enough to make it
funny like it well for me then talking
about like going through abuse and [ __ ]
like that
you know a maturity of a comedian to get
to that way cuz louis c.k
you know they're hilarious and um with
the other one from the audience comedy
bill burr yeah he was there sets while
he's my favorite what a tell what our
louis c.k what do the comedian right now
Chris Rock the comedians who are talking
more about the personal life
go watch their sets when they first
started I got nothing to do with the
talking about right yeah yeah it's just
you're gonna grow out of it and do this
podcast buddy helps you you'll get used
to it you know talking about it more I
don't know how fun is gonna be that's
like a Birbiglia per baby so what yeah I
start talking about abuse in my shows
but took a while yeah yeah you got the
one about your mom yeah [ __ ] that's why
you got room at oh I don't doubt it
myself you know and they're like I don't
know cuz I thought because my dad keep
coming back I know like cuz him and now
him in my life I won't let nobody come
back after like hitting me you know or
hitting somebody I love you know but you
grew out of it but I understand how you
can live your day to whip your ass poor
yeah but I would [ __ ] break windows
and [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up like fires
you're a pyro I'll do whatever dude
[ __ ] shoot but I stab my cousin in
the back of the knife one time [ __ ]
that's crazy
no time I was like [ __ ] I got this
golf club in a golf ball and I just
[ __ ] hit it and broke the next-door
neighbor's [ __ ] a sliding glass door
I forgot about shooting birds I said the
neighbors parrot dude me dog did the dog
leave after that kick yeah yeah see hold
on Nick cacao just know he just
straight-up kicked him like the fact
that he kicked I'm lifting him up
dude the guy that would have [ __ ] dig
oh that's the kind of [ __ ] I just
remember is those little snippets I
remember him happy
man you don't know what the buzz going
on he's just walking he said look at
that let's kick that's the only that's
the only thing about that dog I remember
is seeing him I can vividly see him
getting kicked into the door like I know
there's stuff like that like that or
talking about my cousins like I've tried
to do that like six times I managed to
make it funny once well still because
that's where I talked about it the first
time I was on here my cousins were the
only two Americans seriously injured in
the London bombing oh that's right yeah
isolate that buddy I mean justice
justice I mean just the circumstances
around it I guess you know I don't know
it's uh I feel like like what's this
Steve Martin talked about that and is in
his book born standing up he said that a
joke is the release attention and it
took me a long time to figure out
exactly what he means by that but I feel
like any way you can build tension as
long as you can release it then you can
make it funny so you could build tension
with any emotion and I I kind of want to
build my set eventually to cover a wide
range of emotions but like make it funny
you know [ __ ] pound puppy I just I
wanna I want to be able to talk about
real [ __ ] I don't want to just you know
that's why I like something like I mean
you see my set evolved over the last
couple years like I'm starting to add in
stories about [ __ ] that's happened to me
and stuff like that and like my
experience isn't whatnot and it's like I
wanna I want to get more towards that
you know okay I also like [ __ ] with
people I've come to find so some of my
jokes like I say something that kind of
[ __ ] with them so I don't know I'm like
I'm figuring out the [ __ ] that I like to
do but I want I want to be able to at
some point get more towards doing
I don't know realer [ __ ] you know what I
mean human that's that's like when I saw
when I saw Birbiglia is my girlfriend's
boyfriend is the first time I saw
someone be really that vulnerable on
stage as a comic
I thought that's and and after that like
I saw a bunch of specials drop where
people are like talking about more real
[ __ ] and I it seems like that's the way
comedies going it's just like people are
talking about [ __ ] like bad stuff that's
happening to them and make it funny you
know yeah man
the tragedy yeah I mean that's tragedy
plus time yeah joke about the magician's
ever in your relationship yeah I've been
promoting my HBO special that's on
September 30 at 10:00 p.m. East Coast
all week bro I got to meet the man bro
yet last night who Mario Lopez okay
Haley I did Mario Lopez show on the
radio and man as soon as I walked up to
him I showed that old-ass photo of him
and I and then we talked about a lot of
stuff we talked about a lot of stuff off
the record and it threw him off I threw
him out of character at a time which I
liked doing and he appreciated that that
fool is polish bro like polish you know
like man I had to get with my publicist
to get ready for the interviews to write
to answer the questions right keep the
answers short keep it under a minute you
know the the interviews are not that
long so you got to keep it brief you
know keep the momentum going
he he Mario Lopez
you know he doesn't look like somebody
that works hard but he works really
really hard at what he does and you know
I'll give that for a lot of credit man
because he's very professional like he
did my interview it was fluff but it was
perfect we laughed on the side but then
they rushed him out of the interview out
of his little studio to go do another
interview like my interview was done
during a lunch break got off pop another
sandwich
went into another room pushed out two
more interviews and then when I go do
mom Holly his other show access and more
interviews you know he does so others
know integral he'd go for the [ __ ]
hotel rooms oh yeah [ __ ] yeah whoo that
Fool has the [ __ ] cleanest teeth ever
seen anybody
AC Slater doctor Oh
love and Water Pik and we start talking
and I say bro I know a friend of yours
um I went to a birthday party there for
your cousin one time you know they were
on with Willie Barcena oh really
[Music]
ah man me him we got drunk one time and
he wanted to wrestle me they did wrestle
bro
and I'm thinking about [ __ ] Willie oh
that's the little guys bro
little Flaco the only time was to
wrestle big duel I was eager if if he
has to be a good position yeah so shut
out tomorrow Lopez I did a little video
with him me and my Lopez you got my know
him from colors and that he did the two
one dog he's a little [ __ ] a
billboard looks badass person yeah man
well you saw that and the picture no no
the way the video you did he's put a
picture he said he hadn't seen it in
person it's right it's right by the
Laugh Factory dude across the street
right
yeah it's by the McDonald's there's what
four or five of them [ __ ] five bill
that's that's so [ __ ] awesome
so what can people find you at Adam
Murray live uh yeah at Twitter and
Instagram is at Adam Murray live that's
M you are our a why I go ibe Adam I got
Adam Murray live.com you got links all
that [ __ ] commercials yeah yeah I did a
uh I don't know I don't I don't know
what's airing now I've done a bunch of
different stupid commercials like for
Circle K and he's playing Robinson
Caruso an oblate o on the same night
your special comes out I'm on swamp
murders the for Investigation Discovery
I play a bartender on an episode of
swamp murders [ __ ] that you'll be the
swap it's like a crime reenactment show
doesn't remember this map but I'm Adam
Murray will with us when we're working
with Mike Epps in Orlando and he was a
gather sneezed on our senior house okay
you want her on Bruce blues guy y'all
brought that white boy into my room when
I leaned on the yeah when I take a
picture of Bruce versus cupcakes he was
like what the [ __ ] is he doing my
cupcakes no but you saw his body
language right now I mean anybody
Carolina cupcake girl like Earl didn't
touch this cupcake but he was so he was
like he was like getting ready to jump
out of a seat I've never seen a fat man
want to move so quickly he was probably
the only one there that actually ate
their cupcakes
I ain't mine no no we didn't need them
but you took out you took Arsenio's you
keep I didn't keep a cupcake okay you
had a Raider one a daughter
I kept what's a full one in the Arsenio
one this is still in your freezer no I
started my freezer because I didn't have
a freezer in the hotel room so it kind
of started melting and [ __ ] so I got
pictures up it was cool did you eat it
no oh man I bet that was delicious those
I'm amazed at how much time they put
into that like to know they they they
made like four cupcakes for each person
and they're all individualized my
absolutely good to my cupcakes Fridays
do we come in there man that my camp
came in and then foo and I we had all
the food with all the beans out rice
yeah dude the thing that was the thing
that was crazy to me was that we got
there early we got there super early and
craft services wasn't even setting up
until like Showtime cuz they knew
everyone else is gonna be late and even
the crowd was coming in late they that
with it's startling what thirty minutes
late yeah three minutes at least and we
were just walking around going I don't
know why ever here so early like
everyone knew but us
nobody knew know who we were the curl
was off we got a show coming up the 17th
this Sunday at flappers comedy in
Clermont and the 26th spray improv you
got shows coming up in Florida
um Edinboro being Orlando doing the
cleanup for hurricane haha
I got almond Jacksonville on the
twenty-ninth dad please bloody at
Maggiano's apparently model which i
think is a fancy it's just like a fan my
gr lows it's a good chain italian
restaurant but yes i its i eated it ate
at the one in denver colorado and then
the one in phoenix bro they have the
best for cheese pasta
it competes with Ramon's whatever
Romano's about Mac Romano's Macaroni
Grill yeah I know man the one in
Maggiano's it's like met with cheese on
the bottom and they burn it let me put
the pasta over it then you mix it all
it's like a little pile and man have you
seen the new [ __ ] they're doing nah tell
me they get that big half of Jack the
big cheese you show me move it fool they
cut it into your food or slice they took
it they took it took it too far this
time bro wow this guy burned with a
torch all the cheese on top like a creme
brulee yeah I got burned and then he
scraped it the melty cheese on top of
guys burger in his table I've seen like
that I've also seen it where they take a
giant cheese wheel and they heat it up
and then they dump the spaghetti in
there and smack it around
I've heard that stuff's expensive but
god I want to try it it's you know
[ __ ] get high or do drugs by the
pasta is did [ __ ] use your money on food
I'm at what a time to give up cheese for
me man everywhere now is that what you
miss the most
I miss pizzas bro hamburgers but they
got vegan pizzas yeah like [ __ ] dog next
time you come to Orlando there's their
cheese there's a place called lazy moon
that actually has pretty damn good vegan
pizza trussed up or what
no no they they make these pizzas it's
like the size of a flag they're huge you
only need like a piece or two I mean
really one he's alright I have real
cheese at the prom they have vegan ones
they have they have a whole vegan piece
I only have one good vegan cheese you
know and
called t's te easy and it's he's
mozzarella it's kind of wet like a
mozzarella and they use that to make
Chicago style pizza and um
masa and echo party which probably the
best deep deep-dish Chicago top pizza in
our a that's awesome
yeah the guys from Chicago so when you
order up our pizza there you're gonna
order it before you order appetizers
yeah I'm one of those deep dish what's
gonna be here in 40 minutes okay go
ahead but you know like some deep dish
or just deep dish mm-hmm these put these
right here Marcel they pulled out what
do that stuff on the bottom
they put cornmeal powdered corn me on
the bottom then we put the crust over it
so they used to cornmeal for the the
bread won't stick plus but when you cut
it the cornmeal gets cooked so you have
pizza bread and hardcore Nihal I've
always I've always hated it when you get
good the places I've done I've gone to
the head cornmeal on the bottom it's
like sand almost yeah on the bottles
good I hate that you were so full part
guys take everybody here Lisa over there
throwing now information Aaron back over
here our special guest here Adam Murray
out of the way from Orlando hurricane
survival survivalist
the Murrays with it when they hear this
before San Jose don't leave it out
Friday morning yeah yeah yeah come say
hi in San Jose get more get more palm
pop babies do little be some crazy
people show you know broke even you
coffee that Hollywood with a quiet
little Winston because your step that
gave you a coffee bro oh yeah yeah
they're probably messages out there so
bring old time yeah you wanna give any
shoutouts to anybody who listen we got
listeners in Florida too [ __ ] yeah dude
all that what's the name of that do that
come on sir he he's come in Tampa and
he's come
in Orlando to like give us weed smoke
though you tell me that fat dude that
they he came out for the Buccaneers we
didn't believe oh I don't remember he
can't I think he came Jose Jose Jose I
think he came down to was of the
sparking lot I know you talking about he
went to Fort Myers yeah Aquino former
San Jose shout-out to Jose he comes he
comes like every show that dude is
[ __ ] awesome yeah I don't know yeah
that he showed up one time was a bunch
of friends at the all different
disparate nationalities then he showed
up with it lady my girl in Fort Myers
dude there's the ever there's that
there's also a guy who like moment I put
out a YouTube video he comments on it
that dude I was a frog bro rivers name
is he likes the bus I put I put when I
was like wow so foo like just that kind
of [ __ ] I love man it's nice what's so
fool what so fool podcasting everybody
for listening don't forget man right at
the review check us out on Instagram let
us know you're listening
take over a label I don't worry live
take three seconds to go through all
these photos here line he celebrates
every minute of life I try man that's
what that's what life should be human
you're the Yemen yeah man